so for either of you what's the way to
mentally psych yourself up if you are
getting knocked down even in the ring or
in life dealing with people that you
don't feel comfortable around we don't
think they're being truthful with you
something doesn't feel right well how do
you how do you keep that that game face
on ah for me it's it's stick to the plan
it stick to the plan you have to know
what you want out of life first before
you you know so you're not sweet you
know by you know other distractions or
anything like that so once once I know
what I'm going after I can move a little
bit here but I'm still going forward
I'll still go on and Ford your head so I
mean how to keep my game face I just
stick to what it's real in it and I told
myself a everything that I've been
through all the bad things the ups and
downs they're meant to be for reason but
that reason will never reveal itself to
me if I quit it will never be shown to
me what all this was meant for if I stop
now so if I want to find out I got to
keep going if I want to make everything
that I've done it from this point on you
know mean something that I have to keep
going because it's not then it all meant
nothing and what are we doing here life
is to live so that's what I'm all about
you know yeah you just I just keep I I'm
very careful who I bring in and I'm very
close and I close everybody out I'm very
careful i bringing because very Hawk me
to trust people period I could count on
this just in one hand how many real
friends i got from all my own all the
years uh because I've been in this earth
in here in LA and in New York 52 friends
that I guess I could count you know so
as I I kind of keep myself closed mind I
don't I don't a lot of people in this is
very hard to trust people got people
that was stabbing him back but again and
it was again I didn't talk to him for a
year did I didn't know where he was
about as funny that was that was
actually the best way we could have
known each other that we could have met
each other because same way
uh you know again you know going through
all the ups and downs of you know in my
music career trying to you know make it
in the music industry and then this one
you form alliances yeah you meet people
that are on the same path as you and you
guys want to ride together but then
something will happen up while it's all
sweet at school but then something bad
will happen and the fracture happens and
you know there's nothing wrong i had no
animosity towards anyone else there that
happened to but it happens and you end
up moving on in forging ahead so i was
at the point in my life where I'm just
like I'm not messing with anybody who
doesn't have the same level of
discipline and determination and
everything that I have and it was like
it was perfect for us angel and I to
meet that way because it's you know it's
what I'm very skeptical about like again
I've got so many things that I'm trying
to do with my life and at least timing
wise with eight hours with my day job
eight hours with my passion I've only
got into how many hours to hang out and
actually talk to people not much so if
I'm gonna invest that time then you know
it's gonna be you know someone that said
it's really all that I I connect with
and that's why was it was cool angel and
I met the perfect way because I don't
think we would have met speaking man I
don't think we would have met talking hi
I'm Chris hi I'm Angela uh yeah we get
along I don't think we've ever met that
way and would have met and done all of
this together but the fact that we knew
each other for a year I absolutely knew
him before I even talk to us it was like
oh you're gonna give angel a ride home
of course come on and it was just like
no hesitation were you in that never
even know where you live let's go and
then he's telling me about the project
and you're telling me how I got this
opportunity but they wanted to tell if I
can act and they don't know if I can act
in this Daniel I need a project that he
doesn't know I'm a writer or anything
and then you know i molded over for a
day or two and it was just perfect it
was at the transition I was in it just
seemed like the right choice to give the
film to another fighter and him totally
made sense to me and you just have one
of those moments in life where it was
just like this is the way it's supposed
to happen and that's why we're here and
when when I met was like I was supposed
to give it to him and I was just like I
well I got this script and he was just
like you're a writer and he's looking at
like
talking about it it was just like yeah I
got the next day it was like hey it'll
hit take a look at that I'm right where
you get this room it was just really I'm
like you right wait I'm blowing I will
happen we're having speak for a whole
year I'm over there in the car with your
stuff like that unit told me jack
something revving let you bad you never
tell me you're right no just give me
anything look good he said yes he say I
want to do the part and then that same
night that same night we're talking for
is like two o'clock in the morning yeah
yeah too long it was like I want
to do a role I'd love to do this while
said okay if you say you're gonna do it
you have to be there when the lights
turn on and when it is actually the
rubber meets the road and it's time to
do it you've got to be there cuz I'm
gonna go from this point on it when I
start I don't stop and he was like I
don't either it was like I that next
morning I went up and I bought the
materials to make the walls for the set
for the wait and the reason why the
walls was so important was because I
tried to shoot the weight before and I
fell short of my budget I had my crew
lined up I have my cast I was gonna play
the role of Rhys taylor and i had my
cast and everything set up and two days
before the shoot I learned something
production insurance I didn't know you
needed that to rent walls and I was just
like oh and i went to go you know get
the deposit for the walls and it was
just like okay so give us this
additional where's your insurance I
don't have insurance I didn't you guys
didn't tell me I needed that oh ok well
just give us an additional three
thousand dollars and you can have the
walls it's no big deal and I'm like
three thousand dollars I was barely
making a budget as it was so I had to
scrap the production and you know and
that hurt but the one thing that I did
that was very important was that i paid
the crew anyway because a lot of people
you know took their time off for
neighborhood they were doing it and it
was just like that you know they went in
a took me cancelled other projects and
stuff like that so i got everybody
together said i can't make the money but
here's your money and I gave it to Pete
Villani the defense and pay the crew he
said no no no not should pay the crew
well so it was funny was years later now
a year later
angel and I are talking and now I need
to go now because he had a deadline
there was no vember and he needed to
have something that could prove he could
act by January so we needed something
now so i started going first phone call
was Pete I hadn't spoken to him and
since a year from when everything fell
apart and I thought Christopher miles i
was i was trying to shoot that sure that
didn't happen you remember me of course
I remember you just said yeah that I was
like what I got the money now can you do
any i'm available he's like you know
what I'm gonna call up the whole crew
every single one of them came back and
they all remember I remember that guy he
was the guy who paid us for nothing
because he couldn't make it and they all
jumped on the chance and we came back
and we shot the weight and as I was able
to get my crew in like three days and
build the wall and we ended up shooting
the weight like what 29 days later we
were shooting the weight you know and I
ain't got a gun and that was the first
one in the bag so this benek is been a
long journey has been a great journey I
love looking back look I'm going forward
with it you know what I made it but I
love looking back and seeing where we
came from but I don't look back long as
I keep going you know and so going back
in a town where everybody comes up to
you hey what do you do they size you up
so they can see are you abused to meet
you I need
network with you you guys watched each
other for a year and and from that
determine okay I can trust this guy I
can trust this guy mmm you know that
it's not gonna work for everybody you
know it's just a unique circumstance for
us because of the people we were in the
environment we were in that's just how
it was you know what I mean it was just
all you know if I mean Abby's in the
middle it's a Tennyson touchy situation
when two alphas me it's touchy cuz you
can either hate each other I love each
other is one of the other so it's just
like an utter a job just like man when
we will vote fighting I don't know and I
was to say we would either loved each
other or we were to beat the crap out of
each other every time we saw each other
anytime we saw something doesn't do good
as I am go get like that so it wasn't I
think you know it happened that way
because it was supposed to have it that
way because you know it had to it was
the only way we would have connected you
know this way this heart because we
wouldn't got up and moved for each other
so fast if I didn't have that year I'm
feeling like I knew who he was and just
shook his hand and he told me the same
thing I wouldn't a jump for him I
wouldn't have been like let's go do this
and bought the materials that start
building the wall the next day it had to
happen that way or else it would it
happen so we didn't talk for it was just
like hi what's up later medical say I go
over there you go one point is in one
corner it also all right I'm gonna pit
I'm grabbing somebody and after a while
we think it's not like
let's do this I'm or down your Chris you
got yeah okay let's go through every
banana outfit look at them then I was
good so and you know it was perfect so
yeah yeah again trying to make something
matter out of all it is so we want to
make it matter out of us meeting and
doing these projects and that's why it's
cool to look back but we were going to
keep going forward
you